قد تكون الحراره هي السبب او غياب الحماس
للمرشحين ولكن مهما كان السبب التصويت في
مدرسه طلعت حرب الثانويه الفنيه بوسط
القاهره كان بطيئا ومتواضعا ويبدو ان
الحبر الذي وضع على الاصابع عند التصويت
لم يكد يتلاشى قبل ان نوضع مره اخرى بدوله
الاعاده وهنا يظهر من الروتين والشعور بان
كل هذا التصويت ان يؤثر على مجرى حياتهم
الانتخابات والعمليات شويه
قبل اشهر قليله كانت الاجواء اكثر تفاؤلا
عندما ذهب الملايين للادلاء باصواتهم في
اليوم الاول من الانتخابات البرلمانيه في
نوفمبر تشرين الثاني الماضي الشعور بالامل
والانجاز ولكن قضت محكمه
الخميس الماضي بحل البرلمان الذي تم
انتخابه خمس مرات تركي تصوت وهي تحمل على
كتفها
البالغ من العمر خمسه اشهر
محمد مرسي مرشح الاخوان المسلمين
في الثوره عندما كان رئيسا للوزراء في عهد
الرئيس السابق حسني مبارك
المهندس المدني
ويؤكد انه ايا كان الفائز يجب التعامل معه
بحذر حاله
بصرف النظر عن السعودي والهبوط والتشويهات
والتشنجات التي تلت الثوره الشيء الاهم
وهنا هو التغيير الذي حدث في العقل
والتفكير كما يقول ها نشكر الله
اصبح المواطن يشعر بان لديه حقوق وكرامه
وهو مقتنع بان بوسعه التغيير وهذا شيء
جديد جدا بالنسبه للرجل كبير بعمره القاده
كانوا ينظرون للدوله على انها لخدمتهم
وليس العكس وهذا الشيء جديد للغايه
ويبدو ان عمليه التصويت ستصبح عاده
والمشهد السياسي سيتكرر ولكن ما يبعث على
الامل هو ان تصويت المسلمين يجري مع
المسيحيين والعلمانيين مع المتدينين
والكبار مع الصغر بينما يشاهد ويتعلم
الاطفال غير المسموح لهم بالتصويت